citizens the reject Nation it's time for
Loki episode four of season 2 don't
expect five and six to get up this early
I'm telling you that much guys so just
be grateful for Now ladies and gentlemen
first things first I want to say thank
you to all watch that interview that Koy
did With Yuri lenthal for Spider-Man
game was a great one thank you for all
the support there if you haven't seen it
go ahead watch it speaking of coy coy
how are you very excited to be here
that's what I love to hear John Haro I
couldn't be 15 times more excited than
Coy is or aoris uh ladies and gentlemen
leave a like on this video that' be very
much appreciated subscribe click the
notification Bell get notified when our
reaction for the next episode is Loki is
up on the chat watch with copy Avail
over page Reaction watch included this
intro is
short green means PR there you are the
TVA is in danger I bet we find out this
episode he pruned himself think so
Theory
different tune every Marvel studios's
logo nice
Multiverse lost him in the circuits of
time dter
timelines color me intrigued nice
open right where we left off he wasn't
always alone there's something you have
to see you were with him are love
tape little diarama so it's almost ready
oh my God a Utopia at the end of time
for us for all time always always this
is for the recording great call R RN
Slayer you are Marvel you are quite a
Marvel I would be proud to lead with you
but not as my partner you made a
difference in this war thank you for
being on my
team the TVA awaits our commands our
commands shall we
go I'll catch up oh how is he able to
wipe memories in a long road see you
soon it's crazy Miss minutes has all the
information is it every time anything
she is aware of pull up protocol
42 is it time arase her memories how did
he do that erase all their memories if
you say so
Order
66 I'm
sorry
regret it's the guy restarts the video
game every time he falls down high score
I helped win you didn't just help it was
you who commanded the
army so he built this little Tower and
while he sat on his throne I continued
to do all the work to keep him there no
one would believe a woman could do this
guys come on the power Dynamic what are
you proposing that we don't need him
maybe we never did M no oh miss minutes
destroy the patriarchy Miss scorn minute
lover man I've been getting theories
right the most obvious theories I've
been getting right and they have been
correct because you just need to read
like one
comment tie some [__] together Source
material perhaps
relevant
oh boy
welcome that's what a great shot he's
lighing right in front of him what he
could be what he is what he's been
wow the weight of that seeing what you
built and then literally
you any of this look familiar Bud
you're
[Music]
hello stop what do you want with me
temporal Aura come with us and we'll
show you that didn't sound as reassuring
as you hoped it
would only imagine what Ren Slayer and
Miss Min have been saying about us but
it's not true unless I said something
good I'm from Chicago I don't trust
anyone oh it's a party
hello you all want me Rona wants me the
effervescent clock lady monster thing
yes that's your loom and you're the only
one who can help us fix
it great response so do is alive she's
in holding with the others we can't keep
them there forever what do you want to
do you tell me I subtle o Crush Zoom I
know what we would have done in the past
pruned all of them there's a lot of
shots like somewhere what vois she is a
general and she wants to protect it at
all costs that was her Mission and it
can be again if you can convince her
this a tall in order seem pretty
committed to the old way your words
changed
me there's always like something bigger
is watching yeah it makes it really
ominous and unnerving time itself
watches chocolate soup could we just
take a take a look trust me it's not
that great later later man you're here
to solve one of many PRS then you're
free to wander around all you want just
love how quirky he is that'd be so hard
to stay focused
Victor this is Casey and OB let's see if
Obi has any familiarity OB that's right
he admires Ora Boris from the book you
wrote the TVA handbook but I learned
everything I know from a brilliant 19th
century inventor in then Victor timley
wow an Ora Boris of learnis that's a
brilliant this moment what did you say
your name
was
Victor your work is based on his work
and his work is based on your work
exactly which came first it's like a
snake eating and don't tail yep inscribe
my my handbook only if you inscribe
mine so many people learning this word
is it's the first time he's ever got a
fan club at all these years there's a
model I mocked up with the loom forgive
the shy and slap work it's not too scale
I only got one coat of paint on
there it's okay good honestly
embarrassed that Victor is here to see
it no
SC it's simple one of us will have to
take our throughput
multiplier it will scale the lom's
capacity to manage the backlog of
branches that was created when I'm
keeping up I'm keeping up someone killed
he who remains first person to
acknowledge it and ruined my
life finally much more Temple radiation
out here than there was when you went
out there Ms yeah so much more more
yes you're going to get skinned again
okay well I mean Loki's really going to
have to Huff it then right why it why is
it only me having to HFF it it's your
show that's why you're also God clearly
this isn't me just because it isn't you
is necessar me I your [__] to Victor T
it doesn't matter who it is just needs
to be super fast okay great so what we
waiting for let's do this step in Victor
yeah working magic it's only theoretical
because our throughput multiplier does
not yet work why doesn't work wait I
don't know I feel like we're watching
the rise of a villain right now 100%
he's about to do something out pieces
your multipliers do put capabilities how
does he take advantage of this I had the
same problem with my loom until I made
this my priced possession a protal typ
wa does It remix figure inating them if
that would even work would take a long
time a long time always if anyone can
it's you and
me oh
no okay come on dude I so on Sylvia's
side about
everything the level of distrust I'm
like way with let's have a little pie
while we wait have a little pie so you
must have some idea of what's Happening
everything is turning to [__] o and you
want to leave it to them while we go and
have some pie great idea M hey Sylvie
what are you going to do clocks don't
tick at the TVA do they H you found out
you're a variant and you haven't even
looked have you it's interesting
lighting keeps coming back to this once
he knows it's real it's real to him
doesn't matter if a you disappear
because you've never bothered to look if
one of them was yours who cares if a few
just disappear keeps from remove that
smart dis associate Joy
pie I like that they lit him like
angelically and her are like evil but
she's right about how he's absolving
himself by ignoring or maybe the
lighting is a clue oh listen
up we don't have any
weapons lead the revolution my friend I
think if we put our heads
together and if we just try to figure
this out we can get out of this room and
we can get back to our lives what is
this going to be I believe it was
Galileo or or Winston
Church it seemed like you gave up when
you sold out our
plan I didn't know you knew
[Laughter]
that I earned my life I auditioned an
audition when so many so much money on
head shot
classes don't you think you earned your
life
no oh she regrets I mean they're all
lost all of their belief system and
identity has just been shattered I don't
want any of this certainly don't want to
be talking to
you but I know you care about the TVA
and I know you want to protect it that's
the only reason I'm here you had good
intentions if we have to fight to defend
this place can we trust
you you're serious they do want the same
thing at the end of the day I care about
this place these
people I'm just going to spend the rest
of the reaction like this banged up bed
up Y what if they don't go for it go and
help mobas keep an eye on
timely this feels more like the pace and
the tone of the first episode yeah I'm
really enjoying it I do wish we had a
little bit more time with docs before we
started getting all this stuff though
agre I had a little bit more emotional
investment in some of this [__] with her
the plot is good but uh yeah connection
yeah the whole like is there an episode
missing here didn't plan on coming to
Pand hey McDonald's got apple pies did
they prune that
timeline who's the Pand timeline I would
like to visit Pand this is All That
Remains of the Pand timeland P who
remains not the pies no for all pie
always he's just trying to see in the
dark like the rest of us o good line I
asked for your help and you walked away
just so we're clear no I didn't I'm here
aren't I again is he couldn't kill him
yeah couldn't kill him time he just
looked so scared he who remains wasn't
scared I love how these two are in their
own weird Indie Melo drama some years
ago my brother was banished from
Asgard and sent to Earth I remember that
and when he came back he was different I
remember that another I thought it was
weakness you spared timely's life and
because of that the TVA and those
timelines Will Survive there's a chance
putting a lot of faith in those three B
what else do we have don't forget docs
she's part of the TVA all those dead
branches those dead people they're
individuals though you know what about
those branches that are still living
that's because of Mobius and B15 and
those guys back there OB and Casey who
are part of the TV it would just be
easier to burn this place down and start
from scratch raising things to the
ground is easy yeah trying to fix what's
broken is hard him showing his Thor
change in a direct way hope is hard so
timely con for the TVA we hope that the
TVA turns into something good oh no we
hope that timely doesn't turn into he
who remains or someone worse that's a
lot of hoping Loki I mean all you got is
Hope at the end of the day bring him
behind the curtain just send him home
maybe that's a good thing watch him
protect him interfere for good heard
that one before yeah both the
perspectives are so fair you can't give
people Free Will and then just walk away
it's up to us to protect them whatever
we do we're playing God Gods I mean
that's the that's the job the ironic
part that they have be become playing
Gods how ironic you are you are the gods
Gods
yeah oh I love it because you it can
lead down a dark path yeah but like
there's a lot there's big cautionary
tail here what a great debate and a
beautiful shot great debate going into
the darkness I don't trust B5 so I
oh boy oh no good holy [__] oh goody
that there expected there's B15 she's
setting in place her plan to control the
TVA we work together we can stop her
protect this place oh clever to protect
is yourself raona an already assembled
Army and you at a general General Like
Pat over here I know I'm working on
myself I I've been gone mere days and
this place is hours away from becoming a
crater Rafa standing in the middle
waiting to see what side he takes driven
into the ground by two variants is that
what you want you're all variants anyone
who joins me and helps me restore
stability to the TVA will have a life on
the timeline if they want it damn this
is like some Game of Thrones [__] now
man y damn choose your side yeah I like
that he's been holding that for freedom
but also like positioning and then as
soon as he's offered it's like the let
go it's very like symbolic of like this
is how we escape this great cat I
thought you could see the bigger
picture
oh oh miss minutes holy [__] for the
first
time I finally am seeing the bigger
picture o please stop you made a rather
impressive life for yourself on the
timeline love aniac
X5
Bradley oh he's already decided he's
just trying to accept what he just
decided to do life in the timeline was
that good huh you've been called him
Bradley
W damn just
him ug how does it feel knowing that all
of us here would rather die than follow
you out that
door wof oh my God Miss min looking
gleeful
oh
W I love
it oh
X5 oh like a cedral of horror that could
have been you a couple episodes ago oh
and he just endures I wish we saw it
yeah it's Disney plus
Max let's go X5 o Ren Slayer there's
just a puddle of your old co-workers
right there next to you he's like uh
Carl Orban from Ragnarok
now
spectacular got a little alternator in
there what oh say about to discover
coffee courtesy of the hot cocoa machine
hoto machine yeah that wasn't in the TVA
Hat book
give that man some cocoa about this hard
cocoa machine could I take a look this
is a diversion something's about to
happen in that room he doesn't want to
be in there for and he waited for any
excuse I mean what did he to get out I
think that room's not going to be safe
oh we're going to see the mush let's see
the mush come
on see some steamy bones
uh-oh that was definit you're not going
to believe this they off themselves
oh you didn't say the magic word God
damn it I mean he created some type of
machine that was sh ravona in the last
episode but I want to be altruistic and
just he wants hot coco but I I don't
[Music]
trust
what I don't speak
I a featured extra that would have cost
more guy was almost a day
player the hell is
[Laughter]
happening
oh chocolate
soup
yeah God damn it God damn
it at least his last moments were good
right on the line oh my God this is
crazy now we've got a villain team up
sorry you're not sorry at
all oh where's the
device oh I not how I expected things to
go Victor seems good did you download
unauthorized games again no I think this
is so intense man author games again
this is so
intense oh oh he's getting Jurassic Park
too she's taking control of all the
systems that's why the T pads aren't
working grab the multiplier and let's
get timely yeah take the serious major
nipple chills run it oh my God I'm so
tense here oh my
God he turned him into a puddle of cocoa
this is where the crime took place this
is so suspenseful Tim Le gone Miss
minutes is
back docs and her team are dead oh man
All Is Forgiven this is such a good
buildup what a cofy all roads led to
this in episode four I haven't had time
to test it but without timely it doesn't
matter without his Aura I can't open the
blast do w r slay doesn't want
him she wants the
TVA they still
here call is coming from inside the
house said
sit now she's in front of the king thank
ruling God your boy both okay oh jeez
sit down sitting down sitting down
you're going to tell us where to find
your
device oh man I don't want this to end
if you don't like what I have to tell
you an X5 here an incredibly painful way
to kill you it's a very small
box I think you're going to like what I
have to
say back to the showman back to the
presentation there is a machine that
develops hot cocoa
and had a c they call it a dunino if you
find our Spirits would be lifted they
will discontinue it in 2022 and it'll
upset one man particularly his name is
Coy he's watching this
show oh P 9000 over
here wait we're going to go to the open
episode where she comes out the it's
going to be improved himself it's
happening we're going to or a Boris back
to episode one in the episode where they
explained to Ora Boris oh my God it's
all in Ora Boris it's all circles
which means episode 5 is our first new
episode since we know what
happened brilliant brilliant
brilliant right back to where we started
oh my God I think we meet Kang in
episode five this is like some prisoner
of baban
[__] gorgeous look at
that access to
access
[Applause]
oh hot wire that [__]
Tex just a manual elevator
override now who called the
phone oh yeah we probably that's moments
away we're about to find
out still think of Trinity this is so
smart come on
oh my God he did prune himself he did I
know you called it man yes it's episode
one
episode called it yeah and we're all
back as an Ora Boris absolutely called
it get
him oh how strange cuz of course the god
of Mischief wouldn't trust himself he's
the god of Mischief oh my God Dam you
nailed that dude I didn't I thought it'
be an episode epod five thing I thought
it'd be the end before the
[Music]
finale I love how he pieced it together
yep you just see him learning like oh I
got to do
[Music]
it there it is
O there you
are that's why she says
that and now he's the time stuck the the
the the time warping which is why we're
going to see that in more episodes that
we saw footage
from
yep I promise you this will make
sense wow this is like some aronowski
[__] but who's
calling oh please don't cut please don't
cut is it Loki is it Kang I don't think
they're going to cut cut
low great shot beautiful the weight of
the phone hello about time oh
it's I love how casual the reveal was
that was great I could take her offline
if I reboot the system yeah yeah yeah
reboot the system yeah dude security
protocols will go down is Casey going to
go out there D oh Casey's going to
sacrifice himself cuz he's wholesome no
I love
Casey
that is getting worse that's not another
power surge let me
investigate get out of here miss minutes
I can't I'm being locked out oh taking
me offline I'm losing my C
facility I need to tell
you I love you I need to you all T his
fries you'll never be him oh right in
front of him floppy disc
TVA is Victor going to be jealous of
Kang oh look like the eyes were
opening I mean that's a good thing if he
never becomes unless he wants
to what's that his villain what if like
that comic I recommended what if his
villain origin story that's what I was
thinking yeah
which is also an
[Music]
oror yeah let get
spooky yeah puff yourself
up what do you say
X5 fancy rematch no powers this
time [__] that was dope oh Wicked oh
because they're offline she could use
the powers yeah there's no yeah no
security there's no inh inhibition
because normally they can't use powers
in the
TV what's going on you
Enchanted this is
cozy what she's in his she's in him
never a second come here come here what
is going on here I didn't think I'd see
you again so soon she's in him
yeah
yes yes
which way where not bad oh dude she's
probably going to see
elith
yep and then just let him go and now he
has to deal with ramifications come on
hry right here this way over here this
is expertly crafted episode it's so good
first we need Mr timely's Aura scans so
we can get the blast doors open I don't
trust him something's about to go down
just put your head in the scanner is
that safe
theoretically it's all right well his
hairfit do we need need a hair net or
swimming cap I do feel like he would
trust OB because of that reverence but
I'm still worried about what happens
welcome he who
remains you did
it he did stall I feel like I want to
trust Victor I mean he doesn't want to
be the bad guy I have to move fast who's
it going to be I'll do
it sacrifice but case's already out
there oh case's up there oh is he okay
okay okay
time to be
brave good luck time to be
brave it's hard to be
[Music]
Brave Brave Little Toaster it's even
worse than when I was out there make
it I don't know he who remains wanted
him to get the hand [__] in the
beginning yeah does this radiation
activate something if you're going to
get time Powers it's not it might just
be a path
but also like the power of controlling
time I imagine time radiation would
affect your ability to control time oh
yeah is he about to get activated is
this how Kang is born temporal
radiation
wow oh my
god
wow oh my God Mom
spaghetti wo
what do you even
do what
happened he's gone what happened it's
over what is he dead what is it what did
we do wrong I don't know what happened I
don't know oh the
horrors I don't
know
oh the Kings keep dying I'm sorry I
didn't trust you Victor
yeah oh oh oh this
is oh Christ hell
yes what is about to happen it looks
like film burning almost how many
billions of lives are imploding right
[Music]
now how many incursions they might be
being
transferred is this the end of the
timeline yeah no more Marvel Canon event
it's
over that Kevin feige reboots coming
sooner than we thought it's great to go
to the handheld oh [__] godam it God
what a shot to end on end
it it's Darkness the darkness of that oh
my God and Justin directed that one the
first episode and they directed the
first that's why it felt
perfect you Geniuses damn that was an
expertly crafted episode I am exhausted
I tired that was ex that was that was
expertly D Not only was their mom
spaghetti my PS are so that is that is
one of the best episodes of all of MCU
television
period that stayed taught the whole way
it also fixed my issues with episodes
two and some of three it was so good it
retroactively like got me there wow you
have no IDE like that was but you still
have you still have the ability to go to
reject naations
shop.com and get yourself some teas to
support the
channel nipple chills I got nipple
chills the space babies of the Galaxy
this Loki inspired Merch this other
Marvel merch that we got too and then
this shirt right here and then that
shirt right there and then every single
one helps to support the channel in
great ways and man there's some Sinister
credits playing before us right this is
ominous knew and that monkey was
terrifying oh yeah Monkey Shines boy you
get the had Victor timely there shot I'm
wondering if there's Easter eggs for
future stuff or like like references
that we'll catch because now we're back
to the beginning of the show because
it's an Ora Boris and the death of
Victor I think brings about another
Kang oh it must cuz untethering him from
all time I'm I'm curious how that
relates but also the idea that he was a
good Kang he stayed good and I didn't
trust him I love how much of a horror
show this is man like guy got
spaghetti well and on Loki I mean he who
remains is obviously dubious but like
the kangs we've met directly via Loki
are like not overtly evil whereas you
know Quantum Mania is pretty clearcut I
mean he must have been I don't know if
they me he was killed then because they
were all caught up in that in that that
final moment so they must have been
transferred somewhere there's no way
they just killed them but there is that
Loki who was pruned yeah the one that
Loki Pruden himself right so that Loki I
think that's how the time messiness
happens with him
getting yeah because unfortunately there
is one trailer shot that I remember that
we still that's what caused Loki to be
time displaced yeah is him zonking
himself
oh so we're back we're literally back to
now Ground Zero Boris and but time
itself imploding man if this leads to an
actual cleansing of Canon and timeline
for Kang Dynasty and then Marvel can do
I've been saying from the beginning give
Marvel the DSX Macha to clean up any
story lines that didn't work and this
episode could do that I mean I don't
know if they're going to do that man and
then Deadpool just goes out killing
universes that are unwanted not on
purpose uh post credit scene episode I
mean we all thought that mult the end of
Loki season one would lead to a
craziness of I will stay optimised until
Marvel closes their doors let's but in
terms of what this episode did alone
like I like just thinking about what the
episode did I this is one like I I feel
like I would have to process a little
bit just because of how how well done it
is like they have just brilliant debates
all around right from Loki and Sylvie
discussion of the the power that they
they hold and what does the TVA
ultimately represent like this was a
fight for power and choice and what the
consequences of that could be despite
your intentions you know like that's
what was happening with raona that's
what was happening with Doc that's what
was happening Loki and Sylvie Victor's
whole character is about the
consequences of actions about your
attention like that's his whole ass
character yeah I I loved the it's a big
cautionary tale his minutes got merked
Victor got merked yeah yeah Aoki caused
himself to be time distorted and
displaced we still have all the
ominousness of when Mia sees himself on
a jet ski I did it just really stands
out to me that in episode three they
said in case he died you give this to
Victor timely I still feel like we are
watching he who remains big plan because
the way they frame this show especially
when Justin Aaron direct there's
constantly this
and I'm not saying he who remains is
alive I'm saying I think we are watching
something else unfold that was part of
he who remains big plan I think we're
seeing a Kang watch over I think it was
an act of subterfuge of what he was
doing when he was saying that oh you I
want you Loki and syvia to run the TVA
and you guys do whatever you want I
don't think that was the reality of the
situ why else would he be like if I die
give this the because it's the or Bo you
got to start everything over yeah and I
think this is a big part of
and I I definitely think that the shots
where they pull back and they show a
lens of someone watching something on a
TV someone watching something pull out
of another time that's the voyerism
you're describing but I think it's a
Kang being aware it's not him literally
watching TV like the Matrix but it's him
watching yeah thematically watching over
a thing that he has put in place exactly
we'll go into the Kang architect room
next episode and he'll be like this is
the sixth version of the TV hope weally
so many times if we meet real Kang next
week I think we meet real Kang next week
I think we meet a powerful enough to
survive ants yeah and what will he have
to say about
that like guy took my name it wasn't me
God I hope I really thought we were GNA
watch like uh something with Victor
timley it's it is like I love that I
didn't trust him ever it's crazy joh the
Major's trial coming up soon so we're
going to have to ignore that for for
right now uh but wait see how that plays
out but it is crazy how he's he's
managed to play three distinct different
Kings and if you count quantam Mania
like
46 more distinct than the last
definitely felt unique and not like a
bunch of people watching football
game totally that councelor Kang scene
suddenly becomes a little bit more
questionable to me now that when I when
I factor in what they're doing here they
R to something entirely different than
What's Happening Here I feel like Loki
is much like uh W division where it's
like someone watched half of something
they needed to like this feels this
feels like the followup to Loki but does
not feel like it acknowledges quantum
Mania at all and like Quantum Mania
feels like it didn't acknowledge Loki at
all yes which could exist with multiple
timelines and if you destroy a bunch of
them in this episode Quantum man yeah I
like ants look at the end of Paul rud
going like did that really happen maybe
not bro carry on to the next Avengers
but don't acknowledge that movie
um back to the
episode the the the whole thing with
Rona Ren Slayer I I I feel like Rising
um up in like realizing what she really
was before it is cool to see I I wanted
to see more of that side of her because
ravona and depending on what like the
only thing I really read was the one
thing you recommended that that
brilliant King comic where where
Nathaniel Richards does learn about
himself he Meed by he's greeted by a
king and written by Jackson and he's
like I got to stop myself from becoming
this and that he ends up just
becoming himself the act of trying to
stop it is what causes it it is an Ora
Boris and I thought that like maybe
that's what was happening with Victor
timley saying of oh is is he
accidentally going to become himself by
like trying to prevent himself from
becoming especially that Miss Mes line
when Miss Mes is like it's what you want
or like you won't get it you want be him
there it is yeah yeah um and and then
but but raona is very much featured in
that and they do hint at that with he
who remains like he did have this
sorrowful regret when he says I'm sorry
when he's by himself after uh you know
giving the order to wipe everyone's
memory he says I'm sorry in a way that
does seem like sorrowful about it like
he had to make a hard Choice
there and I I don't know if they're
implying that they're lovers you know
because like it traditionally it's
there's a there's a romance there
there's a love but maybe not that King
cuz he who remains was definitely more
of an isolated character than a lot of
kings and then there's like other ronas
throughout time that it can be very much
like Fierce Warriors and we're going to
meet one cuz she just got pruned and I
want to I want to see that version I
mean but if you've been pruned you're
you're you're put into the void and if
you're put into the vo right that's what
happens you're putting where the void at
the end of time yeah yeah but I don't
think she oh she did come back from that
once just now so I guess it's possible
yeah she got back because of Mis minutes
right um but but miss minutes when she
reboots might be able to bring it back
again perhaps uh so yeah I mean I feel
like she'd be going to the end of time
and that's probably where that Loki is
right and they would and maybe I mean my
theory is that Arlo that Loki who got
pruned might be able to because because
in that last EP in last season they had
to enchant elath to distract right
right that's what they did which one's
elith the Big Smoke monster smoke
monster yeah they had to enchant elath
and I think but he had to team up with
Sylvie to do that yes and and so maybe
but that was wasn't strong enough no no
no they did do it because then they had
um Richard E Grant distracting with uh
creating the asard yeah so anyway I I
don't know what I don't know what
they're going to do but that Loki still
has to exist right because there is one
trailer shot that everyone was
screenshotting had I want to I don't
want to remind remember remember
enjoying things for the internet but
that's the only other shot I can think
of that we haven't seen that we haven't
seen yeah that's the only other shot I
can think of there's nothing else that
comes to mind like we haven't seen this
we haven't seen this that that was the
only shot I'm like oh yeah there is one
specific shot we haven't seen yet um and
it's like there's no way they would kill
all these people off so that's why I'm
thinking maybe they weren't killed yeah
that they were actually displaced
somewhere else I wonder what the rules
are of the little jail box thing in that
regard then yeah I think they're smushed
I mean it seemed like there was residue
there seems like there I think jailbox
people are dead I'm saying I'm saying at
the very end here like what happened
with all them yeah oh oh oh gotcha I
think Loom burst open I mean the it it's
a very like this is maybe the biggest
Cliffhanger episode in Marvel TV right
cuz like that that could literally go
was well not not for a finale episode
like for for episode four and like for a
singular episode like this feels like a
huge gap anything come episode 5 I don't
know let's not forget before he was
Ralph boner he was quick oh touche for
those beautiful 10 cents that's fair
that might be the biggest Cliffhanger
between that are not a finale that was
bananas all right in recent memory this
is quite second to Ralph boner right
right after boner in entrance uh I loved
how they manipulated our expectations
throughout that episode I really love
that I didn't trust Victor and I should
have this is really well crafted though
like I I think from a directing
standpoint a cinematography standpoint
the way they clue Us in through what
these characters are experiencing
through their emotionality via lighting
choices when to go handheld how to make
objects and items like feel Larger than
Life and have this sense of wonder and
fate yet with this Ting of like Darren
arosi fantasy sci-fi qualities to it
where it does feel dark wondrous but
also kind of menacing underneath and too
there's a lot of wow with like the
mirrors and and the camera tilts and PS
there's also a really interesting
element of like the philosophy of like
what extends beyond the trolley problem
like what's the trolley problem for gods
and you've got Gods discussing the
elements of the trolley problem but
what's the scope of like Mortals to
Immortals you know what I mean like
what's a king to a god it's a God I I
feel
like nicely
done I I feel like I feel like mob is I
feel like everyone probably got back I
feel like a big reset happened for
everyone at that TVA and a lot whoever
was still alive and I think Mobius has
probably planted back to who he
was interesting that's what I think
happened okay I think we're going to see
some really fun because they keep
talking about that yeah no but I think
next episode is definitely some mobious
timeline stuff and I think it opens
under jet ski and I think we're going to
be relying on and I I feel like the
opening shot of next episode is going to
be that one trailer you sh I'm talking
about I don't I I honestly think the
opening of the next week is going to be
Mobius hun I don't remember it now after
thisis saw the trailer I think the one
time I I no I'm not I'm not even kidding
Marvel loves to do big Climax and then
jump cut to something you don't expect
very specific shot damn F I won't I
won't remind you guys about it I won't
tell you but damn I do you you guys must
know what I'm talking about especially
with the [__] you guys are mentioning
right now I I really feel like like I
know what the the the opening shot of
next one's going to be Loki at the End
of Time Loki in the void no I I I want I
don't know jet ski sounds like that's it
sounds like a here what's fun about this
is whatever the opening shot could be is
next week I could just be like that was
it yeah
I be like called could be like called it
because I didn't actually say the
trailer shot no that was the trailer
shot cesal like I knew was the
cel feel I knew Thanos was coming back
by the way man this was great also I
love that 20 minutes in I was like this
reminds me of the first episode and
that's how good they are as directors
Aaron and Justin are so good that like
it was so their style but I didn't
assume it was theirs because they just
have this tone and Pace they it was a
great you call that right away that Loki
pruned himself yeah I called episode one
and then I love that they came back
great job on the misleading of shots to
make it look like Sy might just right
yeah also love that the Ora Boris of the
the season they let Justin Aaron direct
both ends of the snake eating its tail I
love that they let the style reflect the
director's take I I do th think that
there's that he who remains there's
something very like there's something
about Ora Boris the character not the
not what it means the concept of the
character of obie because there were
similarities between him and he who
remains of characters who are isolated
waiting for visitors and the first
visitor they get in hundreds of years is
Loki
oh and they have all this knowledge and
this passing of information that's why I
was like will Ora Boris recognize Victor
timley in some capacity but he also
didn't seem to have his memory wiped
entirely like I I I don't know there was
like something there like cuz he was
remembering [__] about uh Mobius and
when they had an encounter in that first
episode so he's beyond the wipe he's
above it
but the end of Ant-Man implied the Nexus
level being that means all Kings look
alike so I don't think he's a Kang but
what if he's a construct like Miss
minutes that he is something removed
from time so he's the aaor he's the
self-reflecting art of Kang's concept I
mean why would you name him oror like
his name is Ora Boris it's a little on
the note you can't spell robot without
OB like that is not just some name GI
you know what I mean you know what I
mean though well yeah they talking to
each other is the like something someone
had to have named him that unless when
kangh hermain SL timely knew all these
events would occur they knew he was the
center of the aoris and thus named him
that because he's the one that has to
help them get time solved so he's the
center of this cycle a plant a robot an
OB he's got to be yeah he's the center
the
snake the loop I think or he's I don't
and I know they say Tom Works
differently in the TVA but he seems like
he's been around board for like hundreds
of years 400 or whatever they said yeah
yeah oh yeah living but and I know time
works differently the TVA but I think he
I think he's something made that's what
I'm saying saying yeah yeah I think
we're saying the same thing just using
different examples I feel like it's a he
who I feel like he who remains ma him
yeah I think he's a Mis minutes I mean
we know he he can make convincing
animatronics yeah and what's more
narcissistic than a guy that wants to
conquer time itself than by making
something that would be the thing that
solves it like
heires him greatly like the mirror to
him right like let me bounce my ideas
off you off this mirror of my own
creation who loves me and then he's
Herby and Fantastic 4
confirmed Easter eggs I'm so excited by
this show again yeah no I mean it's it's
fun to be left in a place where you're
like breathless and like Overjoyed but
also like no not two more it's only two
more episodes and I'm going to have to
wait another like three years for This
Feeling Again however long it takes them
to do more Loki I do wish we had a
little bit more time with docs and all
them that's the one that's the one part
of the show that I was like o that would
have hit a lot lot more and that choice
would have been more felt agreed I'm
like but you really didn't really SP if
Episode Two was seven minutes longer
like episode two feeling rush really has
affected a lot I feel like that is
something that was significantly paired
for this because I think there's a lot
of interesting stuff you could do and
they represent an interesting side of
the conversation about all of this in
terms of certain people learn the truth
and are immediately like oh my god what
have I done but other people take a long
time to deprogram or you know to build
the trust to see past the you know
paradigms blah blah blah and like I
appreciated more in this episode that
they went swiftly about it because that
created a lot of unexpected situations
and a lot of great things to respond to
in isolation I think the the uh brevity
of it here and the directness of it here
was good but at the same time uh
especially in light of episode two I
think yeah you could have expected
that's why I'm saying putting it there
what allowed the weight to be here I
think this episode is perfectly paced
but if that had been earlier or we yeah
checked in a little more the past couple
I feel like I've been bringing this up
every episode since episode two as much
as I love this one I put it up there
with episode one for me I put it up
there with episode one oh uh oh I still
feel like like I I love watching Tom uh
Tom Heston because he's Tom Heston sure
he is still just kind of straightforward
dramatic resigned intense staring guy
and I like I get the ark I want an arc I
wanted I want the ark to stay through
I'm not asking for to go back to being
like God of just be mischievous you know
but it is just kind of a straightforward
dramatic performance now and and I'm
missing some personality layers of the
things that made me fall in that make
all of us fall in love with Loki this
does feel he is like essentially just a
a really really good TVA agent now I am
missing I am missing that like I
appreciate the arcs and the lines and
the dialogue I appreciate all that I
shot so much emotion I could have two
feelings about it like I could
appreciate a lot but I'm like but I also
feel like we're missing a lot of we're
missing this complete other layer of the
thing that got us on board with Loki to
begin with respect The Duality it feels
like Ahsoka in only in so far as this is
much more an ensemble than it feels like
it's about its Title Character not just
that it's just a very straightforward
like dramatic character now you know
what I mean he's not as imp yeah he's
not as like rascally or there's no fun
with Loki he's cly yeah he's certainly
not the god of Myster well I think it's
not he's there's no it's not a there's
no fun with him well cuz he's not at
odds anymore with like the bottom line
of what's happening but I love the
intensity that's the thing I love the
intensity at the same time I'm like it's
like with Mobius they still manag to be
have intensity but also keep that level
of fun you know it' be fun but
impossible to do because everybody needs
the namesake of Loki imagine if this
show show was called Kang and it was a
Kang TVA agent trying to stop himself
from becoming Kang so you replace the
Tom Heston part with another Jonathan
major and it's Jonathan major as a TV
agent more Jonathan but imagine if if
Jonathan major was playing a straight La
TV agent that is a Kang variant that was
trying to stop himself from becoming
Kang so he's trying to stock Victor
timley and he who remains from ever
becoming the Ora Boris that is Kang and
then dealing with ob so all that
intensity would like build out both
characters
but now I'm kind of questioning what I
said because I'm like it would make
sense that he's a little bit more
dramatically resigned after everything
he's been through like like I mean he
has been significantly Changed by the
things he se he knows Tru so little of
anything before matters theie was being
you got to get hope you got to believe
in something Heart Break of Sylvie I
mean what it does it doeses
character-wise line up my ridiculous
idea just fixed Loki for you you're
welcome that's what it was
my thing that had nothing to do with
here we are me reflect on you're welcome
IDE is so bad that I like the show
more it wasn't a bad idea I'm just
saying that it no I I think yeah no no I
I think both things can still be true
it's like I'm not upset because the
placement of his character and the
emotionality of his character tracks but
you know that's like a quintessential
part of Loki that makes him distinct in
the MCU Pantheon as well as the comics
Pantheon that he is this mischievous
figure and there's not as much
opportunity for misch I thought when he
was able to do magic with Brad yeah like
that kind of brought me closer to that
place again so part of me is like well
you know the TVA you can't use powers
unless you shut off all the security so
like maybe if we could get back out in
the field there's like more
opportunities for that but at the same
time I'm like clearly like everything
worth happening right now is at the TVA
so I cannot wait for next week yeah I'm
not even asking for to be like
mischievous or or devious in any way
that's not even what I'm really asking
for it's just uh just more fun a little
bit more personality it's like there's a
glimmer of that old lowy charm in there
I guess that's the one simple way to put
it like that some of that old charm
would be nice yeah totally totally some
charm a glimmer in his eye or something
like that because he is the most even
mobus at times and and I think they
confronted that nicely in this episode
because he's so removed from everything
can have that whereas Loki is like so
aware of everything going on and his
involvement and all that that yeah I
think he is burdened with glorious
Purpose with with
glorious glorious
consequences all righty guys well what
did you think about this episode leave
your thoughts down below what would you
rate it I would I would give this like a
solid I mean I like I loved it I it's
like a 10 out of 10 I loved it a lot
yeah I I was going 97 like I
was big fan nothing's perfect going
10.3 all right just just even even a
little better than perfect I know what I
would really remove from it man I
thought that was like one of the most
that was like genuinely sus like it was
exciting and and rare as the day I say
with anything with Disney Plus shows
especially like that was actually not
just a lot of times it's like oh
exciting intriguing I'm gripped but I
rarely say suspenseful and like that was
actually like this is this is intense
this is suspenseful [__] I don't know
going to happen and there were surprises
that just kept happening like and and
and it wasn't like [__] Easter egg
surprises you know it was it it it was
serious and it ended in a way like I you
just don't expect yeah um and I I
thought that was actually actually
suspenseful and I I I don't think I've
said that for any of the Disney Plus
show episodes not even not even lowy
episode one season one um I don't I
don't even think I said it for season
one it's got tension it's got suspense
in it and it beautifully uses the
disconcertion of all the timey wiy
strangeness like it it has that eeriness
that only this kind of sci-fi can bring
you that then like when you have those
moments that's like you know Rafa going
down the hall or whatever like those
read as more traditional horror but yeah
there's just this there's yeah that 70s
paranoia they're all those like subtle
stretch and Crush zooms that they do
like there's so much they do to to just
make you feel like everything is off
somehow and I think that is beautifully
rendered here and also accentuates every
single other emotional flavor they go
for Loki's back on top my number one MCU
show again hundo PE I'm just hoping it
sticks the 6th all right guys well thank
you so much for being here and uh us
with a patron of the day shout out all
right got play some catch up on shout
outs so we're going to do this old old
school old school meaning recent Edition
where we see how good chat gbt is oh
sure we're going to have real fun with
this one we're going to do F Doran and
Ricardo Martinez is all right where's my
prompt where's my prompt chat
gbt I have a YouTube channel where I'm
going to shout our patrons are super
sexy Rejects and then there are Ricardo
Martinez and fev Doran oh yeah I want
you to write a scene only do the
dialogue of
them um surviving a like a zombie
surviving The Purge oh The Purge is even
better yep that's
topical all right so let me give you
some facts about them let me give you
some facts all right John what do you
know about flev fev uh he's uh I think
he lives in
Romania dope uh he's a a big uh like
Marvel stuff fan lives in Romania huge
into
marvelmcu he loves psych loves psych um
flev is a he's he's really ch chipper
he's got like a really positive energy
chipper positive
energy okay what do you imagine his
favorite food is uh I imagine fev loves
uh noi GN o
ccii
sure what do you think you'd be hot dogs
then what do you think you'd be for
Halloween I think fev would be doctor
strange for Halloween would be doctor
strange during The Purge
[Laughter]
yeah totally in what would he be doing
during The Purge what would be his crime
uh oh fev dur The Purge would be he
would be pirating movies be pirating M
movies constantly pirating movies to
last him to last him all 12 hours last
him last him the rest of the year
yeah get a whole library in that 12h
hour window yeah
totally um okay and uh does he have a
girlfriend boyfriend he's got one of
each he's got a girlfriend and a
boyfriend and uh they don't know about
each
other he's worried they'll find
out on Purge night that's not gonna well
but it's legal on Purge
Night uh yeah okay and uh how old do you
think he is I think flev is 27 27 years
old and uh he he got a sixpack yes he
does okay it works out a lot okay
Ricardo Martinez okay Latino he's Latino
good was in served in the military oh
thank you
veteran Loves
movies all right okay all right I know
what do you think Ricardo loves to e
probably
burritos loves burritos tacos
enchiladas ch
he loves
sourkraut he loves BR worst he loves
Bor um and uh what kind of a car do you
think he has oh he drives a Geo drives a
Geo and um what do you think his
favorite what do you think he'd be doing
on Purge Knight um he would be stealing
a a different Geo he'd be stealing a
different
Geo and um How many um I mean do you
think he has any STDs at least a few has
a few STDs yeah gu he's got get to talk
about
it yes yeah definitely uh he he he
doesn't see a doctor about any things he
doesn't believe in in medical science to
see a doctor doesn't believe in medical
science he's a big conspiracy
theorist huge conspiracy
theorist
[Music]
um uh very anti- pirating
movies where he draws the
line and um yeah and then uh what's
another fun fact we can think about him
what what do we Muse about this guy um I
think that loves to stretch and yeah
sure and he's always got a rose clutched
in his teeth always has a rose clutched
in his teeth
and he can't bench very much even though
he's he looks fit he'll drive 30 miles
away in order to release a
fart gotta yeah got to have your
Solitude the one thing he's embarrassed
about oh no um and uh owes a lot of
money to um his mom and and oh what's he
dressed as for Halloween and on Purge
night he's dressed
as uh as a the Johnny Depp Madhatter as
as Johnny de mad
at
okay write me a scene only
dialogue of them encountering each
other of them doing Purge night
together where a huge
conflict arises between them halfway
through the
scene between between them in the middle
of scene that may be the destruction of
their friendship oh
Drama Oh this is going to be heavy doc
all right let's see what goes down here
let's see what's going on people it's
not letting me scroll okay here we go
it's just building suspense exterior
purged Knight abandoned alley night
street lights flicker and the distant
sounds of chaos reverberate through the
valley the alley somewhere close we hear
the sounds of a GEOS engine Pur we got
to do this racist style John okay am I
flever whose race am I obscuring all
right uh Ricardo this is nuts never
thought I'd see the day where we'd be
teaming up for The Purge and you as mad
hat that are bold Choice Ricardo with a
rose clut his to smirking Johnny Dey my
friend
you know you as Doctor Strange is pretty
ironic especially given what you're
planning tonight man everybody has their
advice a few pirated movies won't hurt
anyone besides I need enough movies to
last me the
year F I might be anti-ed science and a
conspiracy theorist but piry movies
that's crossing the line I say come on
Ricardo it's the purge and hey didn't
you just Hotwire that goo I owe a lot of
money especially to my mom's need to
save every penny but pirating that's
someone's hard work man look I
understand that and honestly I didn't
want to bring this up but you're
constantly talking about your STDs and
yet you won't see a doctor that's
someone's Health we're talking
about hey it's my choice least I don't
keep secrets about having a girlfriend
and a boyfriend what's going to happen
if they find out tonight
man that's personal Ricardo how did you
even find out he my ways you're not the
only one with tricks up his sleeve I say
I know I need to sort it out I just
can't bear the thought of losing either
of them and I can't bear the thought of
you stealing artist's hard work plus I
must I might love jles and
burritos but I have found
[Music]
youone you heathens out there enjoying
your
TR so what now we go our separate ways
tonight look live I cherish our
friendship but this this might be the
breaking point suddenly the distant Roar
of an approaching gang interrupts their
confrontation we need to move now agreed
let's survive toight and deal with our
issues tomorrow the two make a hasty
Retreat their res unresolved conflict
looming over them as they navigate the
deadly night to together oh my
God was brilliant that was yeah man I
think every script should be written
by if you want good comedy Chad GPT is
unbeatable is just terrific stuff
favorite line is I might love churos and
burritos but I have
values yeah you can't have values if
you're churro and burrito eater that's
just the Heathen food right there oh
it's my
favorite I just yeah I I I really wish I
could ask the machine what it was
thinking about when it wrote that line
let's ask
it what do you mean by I might
love
churos and
burritos but I have values but I have
values that sounds like people who
generally love churros and
burritos usually have a low moral
standard I apologize for that oversight
the intention was to contrast the
lighter humorous aspects of Ricardo's
character with a more serious stance on
movie piracy but the phrasing was off it
was not meant to imply anything negative
about people who enjoy churos burritos
let me rephrase it leave rephrase it to
look I might have my quirks but I stand
firm on something piracy is where I draw
the line you're right Chad
gbt this rewrite is just not as
funny yeah yeah sometimes you know you
got to smear a community of uh you know
food enjoyers to get the comedy okay I
understand finding the right balance
between humor and clear communication
can be a challenge if you have any other
specific directions or ideas for the
scene I'm here to help otherwise thank
you for the feedback and I'm glad to
assist further in any way can it end
with Ricardo leaving the scene to go
fart but he doesn't want to specify
that absolutely all right let's see
let's see what they do all right let's
pick it up from the end F we need to
move now agreed let's survive tonight
and deal with our issues tomorrow as
they prepare to navigate the dangerous
Street chardo suddenly looks
uncomfortable F I need to um take a
quick detour you know like P personal
reasons just give me like give like 30
minutes 30 miles 30 30 30
miles really now yes now it's Sur
surgent with that Ricardo hastily rushes
off leaving fev chucking chuckling to
himself as he imagines the true reason
for Ricardo's Hasty much better ending
yeah yeah that's true Easter yeah that
was quality all well we did it we did it
guys thanks guys we love you both
dearly stay safe on Purge
[Music]
Night